[Musica]
secondo voi chi versa meglio una birra
l'uomo o il robot
finora gli studiosi si sono concentrati
nel creare delle macchine che fossero
intelligenti ma cosa significa
intelligente subito pensiamo a macchine
in grado di assumere il principale dono
dell'uomo pensare alan turing grande
matematico britannico considerato uno
dei padri dell'informatica
già negli anni trenta si era chiesto se
una macchina fosse in grado di pensare
sera anche dato delle risposte creando
un suo modello di macchina in grado di
elaborare algoritmi di elevatissima
complessità tra l'altro touring è stato
anche protagonista di un curioso
esperimento nel quale con domande
testuali si doveva capire chi fosse la
macchina tra i tre attori coinvolti e
poi è proprio da qui che è nata la
famosa macchina di turing da touring in
poi il grande sforzo del mondo
scientifico è stato quello di creare
delle macchine che pensassero come
l'uomo anzi forse è meglio dell'uovo in
maniera più accurata più veloce più
profonda per lavoro
io trascorro molto tempo a far pensare i
robot cercando di innovare processi
ormai obsoleti mi chiedono quasi
quotidianamente di inserire della
tecnologia in sistemi di produzione
robotizzati mi chiedono di aggiungere
algoritmi di intelligenza artificiale in
grado di prevedere comportamenti
imprevisti o di elaborarne di esistenti
ma forse ancora più tempo anzi
sicuramente ancora più tempo
ho trascorso in passato prima da
studente e poi da ricercatore
i laboratori dove eravamo io un pc ed un
robot
lo scopo era quello di creare e scrivere
codice in grado di far pensare il robot
in maniera simile all'uomo
simile nel riconoscere oggetti nera
afferrarli nel porgerle ed era proprio
lì in quel momento che l'intelligenza
artificiale prendeva forma il robot
iniziava a pensare ed agire come l'uomo
ma in realtà cosa distingue un uomo da
un robot
noi abbiamo un cervello o almeno
dovremmo averne uno con il quale tutti i
giorni prendiamo delle decisioni ma
abbiamo anche cinque sensi con cui ci
rapportiamo con l'ambiente e le persone
che ci circondano
ma il robot ai sensi il tatto
se ci mettiamo una mano sugli occhi
immaginiamo di essere in una stanza buia
riconosciamo ciò che ci circonda
toccandolo beh lo stesso fanno i robot
con sensori disposti lungo il loro corpo
o in generale con dispositivi di
tecnologia varia si riesce a robot di
dirgli di evitare di colpire oggetti o
persone
la lista anche la lista siamo in grado
di dalla un robot esistono telecamere
talmente specializzate con algoritmi di
intelligenza artificiale a bordo che
riescono a permettere al robot di
riconoscere lo spazio che lo circonda
e lo stesso vale per l'udito e l'olfatto
e immaginate persino per il gusto ma in
tutti questi casi i sensi che abbiamo
dato al robot servono solo a farlo
pensare con più autonomia
immaginiamo ora di essere all'interno di
un'azienda che produce un po tutti in tv
abbiamo visto immagini di robot saldare
componenti o montare
out autovetture telai di autovetture in
tutti questi casi il robot fa
esattamente dove deve andare a lavorare
perché perché stato programmato xi con
punti e riferimenti fissi che ripete in
continuazione e con precisioni
elevatissime ma se il pezzo sul quale il
robot sta lavorando è assente o qualcuno
l'ha spostato
beh il robot va in crisi il robot non sa
più cosa fare se avessimo la mano la
alzerebbe e chiederebbe aiuto con
conseguenze poco piacevoli per la
produzione in corso tutti i sensi che
abbiamo dato un robot servono per
renderlo più intelligente servono per
fargli capire da solo dove sta
sbagliando
e sempre da solo a fargli capire il
comportamento imprevisto ma in tutti
questi casi il robot sta sempre e solo
pensando
proviamo ad immaginare questa situazione
e vediamo la da un altro punto di vista
tornò un po indietro nel tempo in
laboratori quando eravamo io un pc ed il
mio amico rogo
questa volta mi chiedono di farlo
sentire il robot non solo di farlo
pensare sentire cosa significa sentire
sentire significa avvertire un qualsiasi
stato di coscienza indotto in noi dal
mondo esterno attraverso i sensi
tutti sappiamo che le macchine o i robot
in generale riescono ad elaborare
algoritmi in grado di avviare processi
decisionali vero ci riescono ad
interpolare grandi quantità di dati ma
riusciranno anche a vivere una vera e
propria emozione ansia gioia felicità
turbamento sono tutte emozioni e
sensazioni forti
che ognuno di noi ha immagazzinato nella
propria mente come la paura di calciare
un rigore durante una partita importante
o il primo bacio o il primo giorno di
scuola o i ricordi evocati noi dai
piatti tipici che ci preparava la nonna
da bambini
finora ci siamo sempre concentrati nel
creare un cervello artificiale ma saremo
anche in grado di creare un cuore
artificiale dotato di anima esiste a tal
proposito una scienza che poi a un
filone di ricerca che permette e riesce
a realizzare dispositivi in grado di
recepire ed esprimere un'emozione si
parla di affective computing raffetti
computing integra l'intelligenza
artificiale classica con l'intelligenza
emotiva
infatti gli studiosi parlano di
intelligenza artificiale emotiva ma in
cosa consiste
è un nuovo ramo di ricerca che si
propone di far vivere un'emozione ad una
macchina di integrare il processo
cognitivo del robot con il processo
emotivo far sì che siano anche le
emozioni a produrre dati che il robot
può utilizzare per pensare meglio minsky
sosteneva che la domanda che dovremmo
porci non è tanto se una macchina
intelligente può provare emozioni ma
piuttosto quanto una macchina può essere
davvero intelligente senza aver mai
provato alcuna emozione
pensiamo a quanto le scelte e le nostre
scelte dieci giorni siano influenzati
dal contesto nel quale ci troviamo ad
esempio quando entriamo in un negozio e
vogliamo comprarci una camicia trovare
nel negozio del personale simpatico che
da una nostra espressione capisce cosa
ci piace di più beh secondo me quella
camicia anche se non ne siamo così
convinti ce la portiamo a casa
quindi una macchina che può sentire ci
può aiutare nelle nostre scelte
suggerendoci quella più adatta a noi la
macchina diventa personalizzabile nei
confronti dell'utente che ha davanti è
sempre più flessibile pensiamo ad
esempio a dispositivi in grado di
cambiare il clima l'illuminazione le
condizioni delle nostre case in funzione
del nostro umore o ancora a dispositivi
in grado di diagnosticare una
depressione un disturbo mentale o
aiutare persone affette da autismo
questo è il contributo che una macchina
che può sentire aggiunge al pensiero e
tutto ciò possiamo realizzarlo con
dell'elettronica specializzata in grado
di analizzare espressioni facciali
gestualità tono di voce posture oppure
pensiamo a dispositivi indossabili in
grado di registrare gli indici
fisiologici connessi alle emozioni quali
temperatura respiro battito cardiaco e
umidità della pelle d'altronde a chi non
piacerebbe avere un bracciale che ci
dicesse l'umore di nostra moglie o di
nostro marito prima di entrare in casa
questi sono i famosi dati emotivi che
uniti ai dati cognitivi permettono alle
reti neurali di capire ciò che è
realmente gioia da ciò che è realmente
paura una macchina che può sentire
immagino che possa un po spaventare
tutti a tutti noi abbiamo nella mente le
scene di kolossal americani dove ad un
certo punto
i robot impazziscono si ribellano e
finiscono per ammazzare tutti tranquilli
siamo ancora lontani da questo scenario
apocalittico
lo scopo di una macchina che può sentire
e quello di integrarsi di più nella vita
dell'uomo
ma non solo pensando come l'uomo ma
rispettando le sue emozioni
i suoi sentimenti i suoi pensieri e la
sua libertà
una interazione e integrazione tra uomo
robot che possiamo vedere in qualsiasi
ambito della nostra vita
ad esempio in fabbrica dove i robot
condividono spazi di lavoro con gli
operatori di linea sgravando lidi lavori
ripetitivi e usuranti ma aiutandoli
quando sentono effettivamente dallo
stanchezza in ambiente domestico
accanto a persone malate o anziane
regalando loro un sorriso quando è
necessario
oppure ancora un robot che può diventare
un nostro compagno di giochi in grado di
modulare l'andamento del gioco in
funzione dell'adrenalina che sente ora
sorrido un attimo perché penso a mio
nonno che gioca a carte con un robot
beh sicuramente farebbero a gara a chi
prega di più beh insomma avete capito
che finora le macchine sono talmente
intelligenti da essere in grado di
compiere qualsiasi azione in completa
autonomia
però forse non sono ancora in grado di
vivere una vera e propria emozione ed è
per questo che la birra
l'aversa meglio robot ma la gustiamo di
più tutti noi
[Applauso]